where does the mind go
uh when it's on psychedelics
I want to remind you of something you
said which is a is a gem
it's not so much the experience but the
degree to which it can be integrated
back
so here's a proposal comes from Woodward
and others a lot of convergence around
this card Harris is talking about it
similarly in the entropic brain but I'm
not going to talk first about
psychedelics I'm going to talk about
neural networks
and I'm going to talk about a classic
problem in neural networks so neural
networks like us with intuition and
implicit learning are fantastic at
picking up on complex patterns uh which
you know so we're talking about I'm
talking about a general just general
with artificial and biological yes yes
yes
um I I think at this point there is no
relevant difference
so one of the classic problems because
of their power is they suffer from
overfitting to the data or for those of
you who are you know from a statistical
orientation they pick up patterns in the
sample that aren't actually present in
the population right and so
what you do is there's various
strategies you can do Dropout where you
you to periodically turn off half of the
nodes in a network you can drop noise
into the network and what that does is
it prevents overfitting to the data and
allows the network to generalize more
powerfully to the environment
I propose to you that that's basically
what psychedelics do
they they do that they basically do
significant constraint reduction and so
you get areas of the brain talking to
each other that don't normally talk to
each other areas that do talk to each
other not talking to each other down
regulation of areas that are very
dominant like the default mode Network
Etc and what that does is exactly
something strongly analogous sorry to
what's happening in Dropout or putting
noise into the data it opens up by the
way if you give people if you give human
beings an Insight problem that they're
trying to solve and you throw in some
noise like literally static on the
screen you can trigger an Insight in
them
so like literally a very simplistic kind
of noise to the perception system right
it can break it out of overfitting to
the data and open you up now that means
though
that just doing that right
in and of itself
is not
the answer
because you also have to make sure that
the system can go back to exploring that
new space properly this isn't a problem
with neural networks you turn off
Dropout and they just go back to being
powerful neural networks and now they
explore the state space that they
couldn't explore before human beings are
a little bit more messy uh around this
and this is where the analogy does get a
little bit strained so they need
practices
to help them integrate that opening up
to the new state space so they can
properly integrate it so beyond Leary's
State
set and setting
I think you need another S I think you
need sacred you need
psychedelics need to be practiced within
a sapiential framework a framework in
which people are independently and
beforehand improving their abilities to
deal with self-deception and afford
insight and self-regulate this is of
course the overwhelming way in which
psychedelics are used by indigenous
cultures
and I think if we put them into that
context then they can help the project
of people
self-transcending cultivating meaning
and increasing wisdom but if I think we
removed them out of that context and put
them in the context of Commodities taken
just to have certain phenomenological
changes we run certain important risks
so using the term of higher States Of
Consciousness yes
is consciousness an important part of
that word what what why higher
uh is it is it is it a higher state or
is it a detour a side road on the main
road of Consciousness what what so where
did we go here I think the Psychedelic
state
is on a Continuum there's insight and
then it flow is an inside Cascade
there's flow and then you can have sort
of psychedelic experiences mind
revealing experiences and then but they
overlap with mystical experiences and
they aren't the same
um so for example in the Griffis lab
they gave people cytocybin and they
taught them ahead of time
how like sort of the features of a
mystical experience and only a certain
proportion of the people that took the
psilocybin went from a psychedelic into
a mystical experience what was
interesting is the people that had the
mystical experience had measurable and
long-standing change to one of the big
five factors of Personality they had
increased openness openness is supposed
to actually go down over time and these
traits aren't supposed to be that
malleable and it was significantly
like altered right but imagine if you
just created more openness in a person
right and they're now open to a lot more
and they want to explore a lot more but
you don't give them the tools of
discernment that could be problematic
for them in important ways that could be
very problematic yes I got it but you
know so you have to land the plane
uh in a productive way somehow
integrated back into your life and how
you see the world and how you frame your
perception of that world and when people
do that that's when I call it a
transformative experience
now the higher States Of Consciousness
are really interesting because they tend
to move people from a mystical
experience into a transformative
experience because what happens in these
experiences is something really really
interesting they get to a state that's
ineffable they can't put it into words
they can't describe it but they they do
this this they're in this state state
temporarily and then they come back and
they do this they say that was really
real and this in comparison is less real
so I remember that platonic meta desire
I want to change my life myself so that
I'm more in Conformity with that really
real and that is really odd Lex because
normally when we go outside of our
consensus intelligibility like a dream
state we when we come back from it we
say that doesn't fit into everything
therefore it's unreal they do the exact
opposite they come out of these states
and they say that doesn't fit into this
right consensus right intelligibility
and that means this is less real they do
the exact opposite and that fascinates
me why do they why do they flip our
normal procedure about evaluating
alternative States and one the thing is
those higher States Of Consciousness
precisely because they have that
autonomativity the the the realness the
demands that you make a change in your
life they serve to bridge between
mystical experiences
and genuine transformative they do think
seeing those as more real is productive
because then you reach for them so
yaden's done work on it
um you know and it's again all of this
is like all this stuff isn't recent so
we have to take it with a grain of salt
but you know by a lot of objective
measure people who do this who have
these higher States Of Consciousness and
undergo that and undertake the
transformative process their lives get
better their relationships improve right
their sense of self improves their
anxieties go down depression like all of
these other measures are the needles are
moved on these measures by people
undergoing this transformative
experience their lives by many of the
criteria that we judge Our Lives to be
good get better